welcome and thank you for joining us for
this june edition of our PPC webinar
series with brad geddes we are looking
at case studies part two if you missed
part one don't let that worry you this
presentation stands on its own I know
that brad has satisfied some fantastic
case studies to show you here and
there's no need for you to have seen the
first episode everybody loves a great
case study of course they show you what
worked what failed they can give you
great ideas to think creatively about
your accounts observing the success
stories of other marketers and their
occasional missteps can leave fraud the
success of your own campaigns in the new
territory so today I'm going to share a
few his favorite case study team with
that past couple of years and he's going
to show us what we can learn about best
practices and they're not so best
practices to improve our own paid
strategies now if you don't know Brad
yet is we need to fix that right now he
is the author of advanced Google AdWords
the founder of certified knowledge he's
keynote at spoken or led well more than
training at well more than 60
conferences and 125 sessions around
several continents he has conducted
probably going on a hundred officially
Google supported Edwards seminars for
success and has trained probably at this
point my bio here says 4,000 marketing
professionals but I'm going to guess
that's probably a lot higher than that
by now I want to let you know what to
expect so before we start take a look at
your dashboard and find the questions
tool there the questions module I want
you to use that real quick to say hi to
Brad that'll let me know that everybody
can hear what I'm saying we know that
you've found the questions module go
ahead and just talk a little notice in
there say hi let Brad know that you're
excited to hear what you've got to share
with us today and fantastic I see Rob
and Eunice and Mark and Fatima and
Daniel lots and lots of people in here
Theresa hi you're welcome
you're welcome Theresa said thank you
for the webinar Brad
all right that's good to know
everybody's hearing what we're saying so
that question Mazel that you were just
using that's going to be your best
friend as we go along the first thing
we're going to do is that's going to
give his presentation that's going to
run I didn't get a time from him I'm
gonna get something on the order of 30
to 40 minutes if you have questions
during the presentation if you want him
to go back and touch on a previous point
give you further explanation and so
forth go ahead and type it into the Q &
A module there and we will queue them up
and we'll get to as many of them as we
can during the Q&A session after the
presentation if during the presentation
you hear something really awesome that
you want to share on your social streams
feel free to do so if you want a live
tweet what you're hearing you can use
the hashtag M and webinars with a plural
let everybody know that you're learning
awesome new wisdom from Brad and make
them jealous that they're not here and
maybe they'll join us next time I think
that's everything you need to know
Brad's going to take over here in just a
second so go ahead and sit back grab a
cup of coffee a cup of tea a cup of chai
glass of wine if it's the evening for
you take a few notes if you need to ask
questions as we go and let's see what
Brad's
got to lay down for us today Brad
good morning it's all yours my friend
Thank You chip thank you so last last
month we went through a lot of case
studies more related to bidding whether
it was doing things by time of day day
of the week call center got actually
connecting been in a call center so
forth today we're gonna we're gonna kind
of look at the other stuff that doesn't
include bidding audiences are something
that if you do a lot of Facebook you're
familiar with but a lot of people
running adwords and in bing campaigns
don't use a lot of audience data our pro
police we're gonna touch on some
audience stuff we're gonna look at some
other tests done on landing pages
through ad copy testing or fur to a
previous workshop we did and it's all
the ways we use our testing data so what
I want to start off first though it is
kind of talking through remarketing
lists for search ads it's such a highly
highly underused feature and it allows
for
and amazing amount of targeting so we
look at where all essays are they're
essentially a way of using remarketing
but instead of using it for display
using it across search so you can make a
list that says hey if someone checked
out on my site then put him in this list
or someone went to my site they looked
around for three minutes but they didn't
thought my leaves form I put him on a
list and and Google shared quite a bit
of confidential data and I saw one in
the finance sector where always says
make up six to eight percent of clicks
but eighteen to twenty percent of
conversions that shows you how powerful
they are however it's all it's all based
on someone's behavior on your site first
so with them you can either change your
bids up or down you could make different
you could use different keywords for
users in a list so a common example of
this is I've got a our local Twitter
dealership but I do some work with on
occasion and they're a local dealership
and they can't afford to buy words like
cars and new cars all the time it's it's
too broad for them but if someone came
to their site previously in a term like
hybrid car well then they could show an
ad for a Prius if you search for a new
car later on because they know you're
interested in this in with them if
you're using manual CPC bidding then
essentially they can be bid modifiers if
you're using CPA bidding or one of
Google's automated systems then it's
just another signal to use now often we
hear things like audience targeting in
this stuff people start thinking wow
that's a big site thing and it's not
necessarily a large site to take
advantage of this for our essays or even
custom apps you only need a thousand
cookies in six months so if you get a
hundred fifty visitors a month to your
site which I'm guessing most you get
more than that you can use them and so
this is a small ecommerce company
they're using CPA bidding and they just
made seven lists that's it they made an
all visitor list they made a list for
each product line and Add to Cart and
check-out that's it
this is
under an hour of work they took these
lists they too supplied them to their
current account they saw a 10% bump in
conversions from an hour of work in this
10% bump is sustainable month over month
over month because they're using CPA
bidding so it's just another bid signal
to use now they have to do bit
adjustments for their shopping campaigns
because you can't use automated bidding
for shopping campaigns but that's it and
so even small companies can really
benefit from our o essays now some some
people look at them like I don't know
how this is gonna work it's an easy way
to get started if you're doing CPC
bidding go make a few lists just make it
all visit a list this will take you all
of like two minutes to make add it to
your account without a bid adjustment
this is essentially called reporting
mode you'll get stats on your audience
without spending any more money then you
can take a look at it we look at this
particular account they're remarketing
lists for search ads conversion rates is
9.8 3% their overall is four point eight
nine percent so we're doubling their
conversion rates from that user list
people come to your site the show is
signal they know your brand now and so
it's secondary actions often a really
really powerful
now remarketing is also great and again
a lot of people are still not using
remarketing which I find just amazing
marketing it basically says how you came
to my site you didn't finish an action
so as you go across the web across the
Display Network I want to show you an ad
alright this could be dynamic which
means show the actual products back to a
user if someone came to your your OTA
your online travel agency and they
looked at a hotel and a flight you can
enamel create the ad to include the
hotel and the flight if someone came to
your site they started filling out a
lead form didn't finish it that's a
great prospect so this same company they
took the remarketing list they already
made so the our work was already done
and in Google's ad gallery they have a
quick way of scanning your website to
make ads for you these are amazing ads
don't want to sit call them amazing
they're great starting places and
they're good ways to easily test out
messages that if you want something more
professional-looking
you can then take your top messages and
hand it to a designer or go to like an
99designs and have them make a nicer
looking at for you
so same company they add our essays they
spent 20 minutes using Google's image
maker to make the ads that was it those
are 10% bump in conversions and while
these numbers aren't huge it's a small
company right the fact that they're
getting great conversions from an hour
of work month over month over month is a
wonderful thing and I don't think enough
small sites take advantage of this now
small sites are one thing right they
don't have a lot of lists to manage when
you get into larger sites you really
really need to think about what are your
marketing goals what is your budget to
try things out and who's your audience
and how much do you want to segment your
audience so this is a very large b2b SAS
company when I say very large they're
they spend well over four to five
million dollars a month with just Google
not including other places so for them
they kind of look and say ok we've got a
lot of different audiences that we want
to target in various ways so for
instance they've a blog so they want to
target blog readers for when they want
to launch new types of content
now blog shares are different as someone
shared a blog post via Twitter Facebook
whatnot they want to make sure those
same users because I'm more likely to
share again actually see anything else
they make so that they get a better
social bump from this now when they look
at their all site visitors they segment
everything into SMB versus Enterprise
because they want to show a different
add different pricing different ways of
contacting them based on it for an SMB
or Enterprise company so an enterprise
they really want to get you on the phone
right they they want they're willing to
do personal contact on online demos in
person
they have to and ask them be the margins
are my slower so they really want to
push the SMB into their automated signup
form to to sign up for the SAS products
now what they have white paper downloads
like most b2b companies do so again
these are segmented in SMB versus
enterprise now theoretically they're
white papers are segmented by their ten
products SMB an enterprise so that white
paper is actually twenty lists people in
a free trial so they offer their SAS
company they offer a free trial now when
you look at and b2b the problem with
free trials is people start a trial and
they look at it for 30 seconds to maybe
two minutes and they never log in again
and so often their free trial here their
reason they segment this is they want
people to log in and actually use the
free trial now again in SAS companies
what happens is someone might use a free
trial but you've got about sixty days
about two months so we either get them
hooked on the product or they're gonna
cancel and so for the next sixty days
and they want to say alright you're a
new your new customer we want to make
sure you understand our help files that
will give you demo will help you through
the product and they really want to push
that engagement for the first 60 days
now someone's been a customer for more
than 60 days then they want to
cross-sell you
well you're signed up for this product
had this product integrates really
really nicely alright so they don't want
to give up on people paying them they
want to engage them differently
um employees are a list what they were
finding is that employees would
constantly go and click on their ads to
find help files so while they've
excluded their IP address when employees
travel they are on different IP
addresses so they have one that's
employees to actually stop employees
from clicking on their ads on TV
commercial with so when they run TV
commercials they will create lists based
on the flight times and locations of the
TV commercials so they can want the same
kind of ads that match the television
commercials and keep these things going
and they have a whole lot more this is
kind of a way to
thinking through do you have different
products how you want to re-engage users
blog posts can be very useful but not if
you focus purely on CPA and legion right
blog posts are useful from a social
standpoint and awareness standpoint a
sentiment standpoint but a silly
conversion standpoint so that that goes
into more the brand based budget we look
at their goals
rafe wallies lists or current pls
negative list stop clicking on our ads
their blog readers so they use a really
great way of also using our essays which
is combining dynamic search ads so with
dynamic search ads you don't pick
keywords you tell Google hey this is
part of my site I want you to call it
could be your blog could be all of your
site these things are really really
powerful and so they're saying here's
our blog and here's our white papers so
when we push out something we want
Google to crawl it and when a query
matches something on our page we want
you to show you an ad so DSA's
automatically generate ads you write
only a description life for them so they
run Arliss a boss DSA's to make sure
their blog content is viewed so based on
visitor types then right they use their
site visitor types estimate being a
price so forth for bid modifier so
raising bids up or down and that's an
easy way then my product type to manage
the target CPAs now visitor type just
means you you saw part of our content
and you did something so then if someone
actually downloaded a white paper right
they they went they filled out a form
and downloaded a white paper step one of
their conversion process well then they
want those users to always see their ads
again they want to use competitor
keywords broader keywords that they
normally wouldn't buy because that user
shown a signal to do something with them
and the ads are focused on the next step
which is a free trial so within a free
trial right they want to get them in the
trial and then a really high bid
modifier on competitor terms so what
they don't want to do is for you to
start a free trial with them and then
the next day search for the competitor
and starfrit while they're so
while they might not buy compare homes
all the time they buy really very
aggressive on bidding on competitors for
people who have started a free trial or
for current customers all right
customers under 60 days they showcase
help files lesser known features um
sometimes some products are pretty
complicated to use and they you they
actually use different extensions at
extensions so their site links call out
their help files call out demos call out
support well they're not going to call
that out for someone who's searching for
the that type of product they offer
because it's someone hasn't Lee needed
the help file yep any be sold first and
then customers more than 60 days they do
use the word brand plus login as a
negative keyword because what they're
finding is that people would search for
their brand click on the ad just to
login so the word login is a negative
keyword if you're a customer but then
the brain itself is for for customers
who are not searching the word login our
positive list modifiers to cross on
other products so you can get really
complicated with it but that's a lot of
thinking right there's a lot to really
think about how you manage that the SMB
vs. Enterprise where someone isn't a
funnel but to show you the power of this
much segmentation if you have the
traffic here's what their monthly Arliss
a stats look like they have well over
eleven thousand conversions a month for
RSA and if someone is search for their
brand term after downloading a white
paper their CPA is two dollars and forty
four cents with an almost eighty percent
conversion rate that's a huge huge
number and so that that's where you need
to think through not just do we have
what can we do right it's how we're
gonna execute on these kind of ideas now
we look at I'd be the be one of the
biggest problems we see in b2b is mobile
devices mobile devices lonna b2b company
and sit there and say well mobile if
someone's on a mobile phone they don't
care they're not going to convert not
going to start a trial in a mold of
in many cases that is true right then
right download our whitepaper enroll
device they could easily share a blog
post but if you have some size park that
requires a complex login they're not
gonna gonna convert some b2b companies
do really well on mobile if they were to
really think through the user base so
this is data for a materials testing
laboratory so if you are creating a new
product and it's a physical product like
a kid's toy before you can put it on
store shelves you have to have it
examined for mercury levels and lead
levels and and how is it you know as
there any problems with regulations in
accidents and store shelves and so when
they looked at their leads right it was
all desktop based say they got a few
leads on tablets for a little on mobile
their converter it's more terrible but
it not necessarily always it's the
traffic problem sometimes it's the
website problem so we think of mobile
mobile design right you've got mobile
you have a desktop websites shown on
mobile devices so these don't get
reformatted well they're incredibly hard
to pick out if any of you can read that
content you've got to be under 25 with
great eyesight because I'm sitting six
inches from the screen and I can't even
read the content of that it's not
designed for mobile device now you can
read this content this is responsive
design responsive good for every device
not great for any one device wonderful
for publishers IT loves it because they
only have one website to support and
then we have mobile only sites and it's
very hard to find it b2b of mobile only
website because they don't usually
believe in this enough and so this was a
different company again a pretty large
spender who has an a locked-down
IT department and in other words to get
a a single word changed on a page means
three to six months of tickets to get a
word changed you want to change a link
you could be talking six months to a
year to get a link changed or your CSS
change there's
three years of wait time usually and so
they had a desktop site and we were just
trying to convince them hey just it's
least try respond to design try
something because we don't think it's
necessarily your traffic that's the
problem and so after I don't know three
months four months of time they we
finally convinced the IT department to
let us use a subdomain cname redirection
to a different server so if something
went bad another server it couldn't
affect the rest of their company and
just installed WordPress used one
responsive theme and one mobile theme
that was it so now we have three
websites we have a responsive a mobile
dedicated in a desktop so we said all
right let's let's use their current
traffic in AdWords we're gonna make
three identical ads in every ad group
Lucent want each ad to a different page
and see what happens
so after a few months turned out that
their mobile specific website had a 6x
higher conversion their desktop for
mobile devices of course not for desktop
devices that deal was double responsive
design for them and they looked at this
and looked at this and went when I
believe it right we we think our sites
grade no one's born will device of
course if the material says I was
calling them or that wasn't people
buying stuff it was calling it to
schedule things and so they finally put
some design around it and kept it due to
IT on it on a third-party server and
after a few months their mobile
conversions Eclipse desktop now this is
one of those sometimes harder
conversations because it's IT its
website there's a lot of marketers who
can change traffic very quickly but
can't change websites very fast now I do
what it says in our case when we look at
why people search on mobile devices it's
arts and entertainment its news its
shopping is really taking off
it's food it's not a lot of b2b so not
every b2b company is gonna find great
mobile success but it is definitely
worth looking at to see at least have a
good mobile presence
and have offer things like white papers
newsletter subscriptions some of your
ability for a user and b2b to convert
even though it may not be assigning it
for an actual demo giving a credit card
let them get the content necessary
especially send content up the line to
to their boss to get approval on mobile
devices now another issue that we see a
lot in b2b is that data set mobile at
minus 100%
now if mobile doesn't convert and you
just don't want to be in mobile I get
where that happens on occasion at least
by your brand terms on mobile device
even if you use something like a 50
percent negative bid adjustment with
Google as showing you often three and
four ads above organic results his users
searching for your brand on mobile
devices aren't seeing your organic
results and you're losing a lot of
traffic to competitors buying your brand
on mobile devices so even if your b2b
and and anyone if you're have a really
did well design ecommerce system but it
only works on desktop for mobile at
least by brain you know it's a really
large bid modifier this company by
tzer's finally and they actually get a
decent CP it's not a huge number right
it's for their 15,000 conversions but at
least now they control their brand on
mobile devices now Quality Score is
tough and b2b because with Quality Score
you really want a great clip the rate
which is tough to get on case I'm going
to show in an example in a minute you
want a great landing page you can do
that you want good ad relevance you can
kind of do that and sometimes in b2c
claudus score is a very very important
number
sometimes in b2b it's not and to show an
example here right if sometimes in b2b
if quality scores are eights and nines
for non branded terms and for terms that
aren't be to be specific they're not
purchase agent terms they're they're
consumer and business based terms
sometimes we see eights and nines we
actually think that they can do better
conversion rate wise by lowering quality
score
it sounds very counterintuitive but this
is a chart of one b2b companies non
brand non purchase agent terms by
Quality Score as quality score their
conversion rates go down and and the
term here is the term safety gates now
the term safety gates is primarily
searched for from the consumers looking
to buy at twenty thirty dog gate for
their pets or their kids so they don't
fall down the stairs or keep them out of
a room there's a subset a small subset
of searchers who search for safety gates
who spend ten thousand a hundred
thousand dollars on gates for factories
and plants so on this search result the
the purplish blue color is b2b ads the
yellow is b2c ads so all these if you
look at the b2b ones closely they're all
industrial they use the words OSHA they
use things like call us for a quote now
what happens here is not only how great
quality scores they could get a great
quality score if they took off all these
pre-qualifying terms of call us for a
quote and OSHA and so forth their Clause
scores would jump up their CPAs would
skyrocket as they get all these people
who are looking for a cheap pet gate
clicking on their ads and so that
pre-qualification the Act is really
important be to be however it will lower
click the rates which will lower quality
scores so next month our webinar is
actually going to focus on close with a
lot of really cool new analysis we can
do with an API changes a couple months
ago now here's actually the biggest
problem in b2b is landing pages because
a lot of b2b companies don't ask for the
conversion these are the two top pages
for the same term safety gates
competitor one if you can find the way
to convert on that page your you've got
great ice sites because the very bottom
in standard text is call us at this
number and a lot of companies kind of
think well someone really wants to do if
I stuff on how to do it in and I see
this even a b2c on like high-end design
firms and architecture firms all the
time now here's the competitor big
download the specs here's our big phone
number
get it quotes so it's the same product
really different experience from a user
standpoint of how easy it is to deal
with these two companies if you don't
ask the conversion you can't get the
conversion alright you gotta ask for it
now we've often talked a lot about ad
testing for insights and and also video
later that we did on that you can refer
back to within marco motive but one
thing that that we often look at or how
do we get insights from ad testing and
then how do we apply that other places
so if your I've been a lot of webinars
list you've probably seen this example
for I'm going to go beyond at this time
so so one is using customer data this is
a ecommerce company who sells
promotional products now they have two
types of buyers they have
business-to-business buyers who want to
buy ten thousand cups with their logo on
it for an event they're hosting they
have consumer buyers who want to put
their kids picture on a cup and buy
twenty of them for a birthday party so
they prefer b2b but but they'll sell
would be to see as well not gonna turn
down the money but it's not their
primary market and so you know looking
through their their reviews every time
someone gave them a five star review
they use the word rush shipping now this
is e-commerce so of course like most
e-commerce companies they have something
that says free shipping in their ads
because free means free right well
businesses often don't care about free
they want something today or tomorrow
they want it quickly and rush it is a
very specific type of shipping let's go
test the ads right let's do fast and
free shipping which was the current ad
versus Russia shipping and ran the test
and said I don't believe this
information
I didn't believe the test result it was
it was done properly and that's because
I didn't think this word would make a 5x
difference in average order value
I felt like we missed something really
big looking at this data and we did we
we missed the fact that certain products
are mostly sent to homes and certain
products are mostly sent to business
addresses so went to their products
intact them and said these get shipped
to business addresses these primarily
get shipped to residential addresses so
it's redo the same task just changing
description line to across you know a
few hundred groups but do it but and
then look at the data based upon where
it's getting ships to in reran it's okay
if it's a b2b meaning the businesses
where it was shipped to Russia ping was
what people really latched on to
consumers don't they know Russian things
expensive they don't want to pay for it
they want free shipping and so just by
changing a single word here I mean fast
and free to rush that's the only
difference in these ads they have a big
difference in their conversion rates the
revenue per impression metrics because
they're talking the language of the
consumer whether it's actual consumer or
a business now this is great insights
you can get with multi group testing but
there's no reason to stop here right
there you got an insight and insight
should filter through to the website as
well to other marketing materials I said
well let's take this data and put on the
website right let's put this right on
the landing page and see what happens so
one was you know free shipping takes two
to three days for deliver the other one
was rushed shipping get it tomorrow for
hours under a thousand items and this
was a point of contention because the
the owner of this business said what
they want you know twenty thousand I
can't do it tomorrow but was pretty
certain this be okay so what do the
conversion rate lift a nice lift but its
e-commerce no one cares about conversion
rates you care about revenue so we
looked at the revenue that didn't work
too well negative eight percent revenue
from their top customer based b2b
companies
and and said well this is significant
change it's right 11% lift - 8 % order
that's significant so we're on to
something we just don't have the
messaging correct yet so went through a
lot of button iterations usually buttons
are over talked about and testing colors
and so forth
usually they're over talked about but in
this case it really did make a
difference and after getting the correct
messaging free shipping orders over 150
that's a it's a really big deal in
e-commerce is putting a limit on your
free shipping in Amazon was probably one
who rolled this out really first like 10
12 years ago they took their marketing
budget and turn it into free shipping
and they put a free shipping at I
believe it was $25 I might have been 35
but what they saw is their average older
value actually increased because
consumers they said oh if I spend $10
more I'll get it free so I'll spend $10
more to get a dollar 50 off of shipping
right this is a very common thing in the
marketing world to see and then for the
b2b companies it click for details
popped it up here's your average order
size how many you want this how fast we
can do it in and that makes that's great
no again not done yet with the ad dad
all right that is powerful so we looked
at the various lines they were using for
D ones for description line ones see
that the two highest click-through rate
by far the two highest click-through
rate right view of finished product and
and customize the font with colors in
your logo or by far the worst conversion
rates but again it's outlier data that's
always important when you say okay our
best converting rate is 6% CTR but our
best CTR is actually double that rate so
how do we increase volume of clicks
without affecting our conversion rates
well that's using your same data in
other places in their account so in
their case they put it as extensions
they made it site links and and you
can't truly do scientific test for site
links
for sitelinks you have to do sort of
before and after tests so when they
added it they saw an increase in total
clicks without a decrease in conversion
so that's what you're really looking for
now going back to audience lists then
again we're not even done yet right this
is the same company who added all essays
and saw a 10% lift said okay well you
know what we can even go further here so
we now know that businesses are have a
better repeat rate for the company and
they know that the business of higher
value so now what happens is when a user
checks out if the user it checks out an
amount over 500 hours or the shipping
address was to a business address they
put them into a b2b shoppers lift
shoppers list so that if they search
again they have super high bid modifiers
because they know that is a great user
to get back now if the user checked out
but it was a under 500 hours or it was
shipped to home address they still put
them in a list to remarket back to
converters but they have a very low bid
modifier because they're willing to sell
to consumers but it's not their primary
business and if you're looking to see
how to get these great multi ad tests on
data for yourself we did a whole
workshop on how to really lay out
exactly how to do I mean testing to get
global insights because these are
insights and aren't from an ad group
they're from an entire segment of an
account such as all your brand terms all
your product terms were just ate all
your SNB product terms now lastly
websites are great places to use you
know some of this data some things I
just want to give you some inspiration
of things to think about at testing data
is so powerful title tags have the same
length especially when Google rolls out
the new title tags in probably October
we're gonna see 60 character long title
tags that's the same as organic we see
really savvy companies sit down with the
SEO team and say okay
in ad right then ad is just anything
written down or any kind of a visual way
of getting of motivating a user to do an
action rate an organic listing is an ad
and PPC ad is of course an ad running as
design to motivate and influence
someone's decision so we see smart
companies sit down with the SEO team and
say hey we know you've got to have
certain keywords in your ads but the
rest of your title tag is really just a
navigate user to click through so
they'll run PPC tests to see how they
should structure their organic title
tags because you can't a be test organic
title tags that's a good way to do it
email subject lines their ads to rights
a great place to use this is just in
your emails another great place if
you're doing like button testing most
emails and with a call to action right
here's a button here's something they'll
click on it's a great place to do it
when you look at web sites most people
are really afraid to a/b test their
homepage or key pages code and
understand that right if you say oh
we're just going to change our homepage
today that's kind of a scary proposition
great way to do this look at the new
home page you want to design right
launch it but not on your main page
launch it somewhere else in your site
and then run your branded traffic to
that new page now you can't ask with
branded based traffic your new home page
but actually rolling it out and effect
an organic or just the overall brand
perception first if you're doing a lot
of SEO right remarketing and in your
Google Display placement information are
great link targets right link building
is still alive and well and if you're
gonna say where did we get great
converting traffic from you have a list
it's in your account already right great
places to think about how you get some
traffic from those pages that are
already sending you converting traffic
remarketing we love our marketing or
marketing is great for influencing any
other channel remarketing just says hey
summited action X on our website and we
want to reinforce behave
of action acts and make them do action
why you can make remarketing list off of
TV flights off of social campaigns so
they came from Facebook we're gonna put
them in our Facebook list and show
different ads to Facebook users versus
Twitter users if you want to write
they're great for email when you when
CMOS are surveyed right what is their
one of their biggest hurdles overall to
deal with them what do they really want
to get done in the next five years it's
better integration of marking apartments
and this has been on the list for I
don't know 10 years now right it's
better integration marking apartments of
what simos want except companies are
really starting to do it now and have
much better integration between marking
apartments a great place to start how
companies work together is via
remarketing so you can say all right
well let's let's say here's the emails
we're gonna send let's put those email
users in specific lists so if their
email user saw this creative and clicked
we know what appeals to them but then
they didn't convert okay so we know this
email could appeal to them but they
didn't convert so therefore we can now
build an ad that uses that structure
from the initial email that got him to
click but we'll change the offer to
something else might get them to convert
and that's a very important
consideration now the larger company the
heart of this is my favorite stories on
this is we're working the company big
big fortune I don't know if they're 100
they're at least 500 minimum and and the
email team had been to one of the SMX
shows and learned about remarketing and
said this is great we can reinforce her
emails because we know it takes users to
point three clicks to convert when they
click on an email but if they're only
clicking on that one point five emails
each so we need one more touch point
from somewhere I thought well let's
let's use remarketing for this and so
they sat down and this was a really good
email team I sat down and said okay
here's that you know we're gonna send
here's a landing page we're gonna use so
if this doesn't make them convert here's
the offer we should try next so they sat
down and made another landing page made
ads and walked the paid search team and
said hey can you run this for us we want
to send out this email
and if someone doesn't convert wants you
to put on a marketing list and we wants
you to show these ass and I said can you
do that and the paid search seems to
soar that's pretty easy what's your
budget and will the email team said well
we don't have marketing budget we have
technology budget or email and and the
pay paid search team said well we have
to have a budget for this we can't just
use it the mill team asked well what
happens if someone comes to the site and
you don't have this in place the paid
search team said well they'll be placed
on our Don converse list in that case
and they'll see these ads Cemal team
said so regardless of us giving you this
that we've made you're gonna spend budge
on these users and they're gonna see ads
and then the pager team said yeah that's
how it works so we don't understand and
the problem was the corporate structure
this is often a problem two companies
the each team are ported up to a a
director level and directors were given
budgets the size of your budget
determined how important you were within
the company and so for the paid search
team to essentially give some budget to
the email team to run this their
director would lose faith or lose
importance in the company right just
made up in internal statistics and so it
was based on that one issue that after
six months they still hadn't launched
this coordination between these two
teams and so that's where GMOs want this
but often it's being blocked by
something else but great ways to start
departments working together it is via
remarketing also you've got customer
match you can upload your email list
your CRM data so even if you go to a
trade show you collect cards at a trade
show you can scan them assuming you have
permission to market to them you can
scan those cards in upload that email
list to Adwords and use your CRM data to
serve ads as well which is a great way
of integrating offline to online so
marketing touch points there's two kind
of wrapping up here so we have some time
for questions right we're marketing it's
great Arlis a is for search remarketing
is for display it's good
for small and enterprise companies but
the larger your account the more traffic
you have the more you can do but the
cleaner you're thinking needs to be of
how these lists all work together and
not just compete with each other but in
reality and fall your conversions where
you call the score at landing pages ads
and as you follow this data when you
find these insights they got where else
you can use this kind of information
across your marketing not just in paid
search to me there are other channels as
well all right so I'm going to turn it
back over to chip here for a second to
see if we've got some good questions and
discussion from this fantastic I just
got to point out by the way for
everybody for my own sake that's an old
market motive page you've been shown in
there our site looks really different
wide-eyed screenshots of the new site
but it's also a great example of the
process that we've gone through over the
past few years I mean I think that you
know in my tenure at market motive which
is going on something like seven years
now we've built one two three probably
five different sites from the ground up
over time and all based on a lot of the
kind of conversion and data crunching
that you're talking I'm sorry testing
and data crunching that you're talking
about there so you know yeah I'm a
little embarrassed this is an old page
that you're showing but it was part of
the process that brought us to where we
are now we do have some good questions
in the system here before we do that
though I'm going to ask everybody to
indulge me really quick I'm going to
take over the screen and I'm going to
launch a little poll here I'm going to
take about 60 seconds or so to just give
you a little more information about
market motive this is a public facing
webinar by the way right so this isn't
just for members only we make these
webinars available to the community to
give back and to give folks the
resources they need to improve their
marketing across all kinds of skill sets
and specialties and I like how to cut
off the title there thank you
GoToWebinar that's interesting but
anyway I just want we've got some folks
on here then who are already customers
of market
who have them are either in there
themselves doing some training or have
their teams their marketing teams in
there doing some training in some cases
we've got folks in there who have their
sales teams in to help them understand
marketing better so that they can sell
advertising space on publish publisher
type sites content sites and so forth
and it's important for you to know
though if you are not familiar with
market motors it a webinar is a series
like this is just a small part of what
we do we do seven or eight of these
every month in a variety of disciplines
so we do things like you see here with
PPC we also do content marketing
analytics mobile social media and so on
covering timely topics both on the
strategic and tactical level but the
core service of what market motive does
is greater than just the webinars we are
a training publisher what we do is we
build web-based digital marketing
training curricula that are used not
only by agencies and fortune companies
and individual marketers but also by
higher education institutions like let's
say Boothe University to roll out into
their education programs they're
licensed by agencies professional
organizations and house enterprise teams
these are structured courses with
streaming videos downloadable workbooks
quizzes test exercises the members get
access to moderated forums where you can
interact directly with our faculty folks
like Brad here Avinash Kaushik and kario
and of course you can also interact with
other students you can make some new
allies and some new colleagues there you
can ask questions about the materials
you can ask how what you might apply the
lesson to your real-world marketing
challenges for agencies and enterprise
and folks that have marketing teams it's
a great way to get everybody up to the
same level and speaking the same
vocabulary to get folks cross-trained
maybe somebody needs to be really expert
in as brad was talking about an email
team but they need to understand a
little more about PPC they can take a
foundation level course in PPC and get
to know enough about it so that they can
speak intelligently with the paid team
when they're building their email
campaigns and thinking about things like
remarketing so it's a tremendous
resource it's an end-to-end resource
we're happy to talk with you about how
it might benefit you as an individual
marketer or as a group if you're
interested in reselling we can talk to
you about that too so take a moment and
pick the appropriate box we'll have
somebody get back in touch with you
there's no obligation but you can get a
tour of the system see what the learning
management system looks like with the
what the environment feels like get a
look at some of the courses and some of
the lessons and we'll figure out what
the best course of action is for you so
I'm going to go ahead and close the poll
here about four seconds three two one
those are fast sections second I'm
closing the poll we're back and seeing
your screen again Brad just so you know
thank you for indulging me with that
everybody one common question we get
this is something that the angel is
asking is is this webinar recorded and
archived in the market motive site for
members only yes that is a true
statement we do record all the webinars
we generally go ahead and get them
produced and put into the archive on the
market Motor site where members can get
access to them we are over time holding
out a youtube collection as well that'll
be available public facing for those
folks who are not currently members
we're sort of experimenting with that a
little bit that's being managed by a
different team over with our parent
company certainly learn and so I can't
tell you exactly when that's happening
and exactly which webinars that might
include but you'll certainly see it in
the archive inside the market motive
platform pardon me sorry got something
stuck in my throat there Brad bread is
asking where can I learn how to make
audiences based off of TV ads and I
think what we're talking about there is
if you're running a television media
campaign how do you bring the activity
of viewership that might be valuable
down into some sort of a list that you
can use in your paid efforts where might
they learn more about though um good
question I mean in RIA
I don't have a good resource I mean in
reality you're just using your your your
Google Analytics remarketing list so
you can either create a specific URL and
don't do like slash offer 23 because no
one types an offer 23 you use a a UI
branded URL that's not your main site
for that offer and its own matterr add
them to the list or you can make a list
that only applies to a geography and
then you can timestamp one of you gets
added to a list so usually what you see
is one commercial errors 90 percent of
your traffic is within 15 minutes and
like 98% from in 30 minutes so if you
say okay if someone came from Detroit
between 837 and 902 add them to a list
and now be a way of coordinating it
there's not another great way of doing
it except using your GA list building to
do it that way and so usually a brand
new URLs the best way to actually just
do it and just put GA across both sites
link it back to AdWords and that's the
easy way to get started it's an
excellent answer I want to put a finer
point on what you said there you
mentioned a bit using a subdomain like
slash offer 25 so it doesn't work so
great so that's practice that we
understand now based on the metrics that
you really need some sort of justice
specific a.com or what have you but no
subdirectories no
trailing flashes things like that yeah I
mean if if you do something like use
offer 23 to get your free trial you can
get some that way but the problem with
that is users forget what the offer
number is now they're trying to make up
numbers to get in there so you do like
you know market motive tv.com raid or or
Macha motive offers.com and that way you
could just use that URL it still has
your brand in it but that way you put
that one on the TV ad or billboards and
whatever you want right and that's
that's what the best way to do it and
you think there's having a branded URL
like that it's better than let's say
let's think about customer intent right
let's say that I'm looking for a
particular kind of sauce I'm looking for
a CRM pool you know top CRM obviously
you're not to be able to buy this but
finding a URL that's specific to the
product or the offer or the customer
intent or better to brand the URL
usually better to brand because when you
type and when you do something like
Topsy rom-com you'll see people search
for domain right you are is so so no
search for top serum to calm which just
means you're now doing a huge you know
marketing you they're gonna see whatever
adds organic listings come up from there
right which is not gonna be just your
brand if you do a brand one though and
they do a search even if you don't
capture them on your your your your
special TV URL you're at least gonna
catch them off your brand URL being
there and so that's kind of problem is
switching the term and someone's had so
usually brand is better than theirs
total sense because if you go with the
the intent or the product line then
you're basically just inviting all your
competitors into the search results so
yeah yeah totally okay great perfect
what's also asking are there any Google
extensions or tools that you use outside
of Adwords and analytics that you would
suggest well I have to suggest the one
because I'm a co-owner of the company
but I'd alysus ad a ly s s is a huge ad
testing automated at testing and so
forth arm that's my favorites I'll use
depending on what people use if they're
using you know a quiz EO Moran can shoe
then I'll use them and they're very like
Marin is great if you need to integrate
your CRM system and robust data directly
into something for bid purposes or like
we're in for that so there are but
they're usually specific to the task
needs to be accomplished but and of
course Excel the AdWords editor very
very important I think the most
underutilized PPC tool is a calendar and
project management we actually have a
video in markup archives on project
management for paid search it's knowing
what to do is more important than the
tool because you don't know what to do a
tool is useless
and I think it all starts with product
management calendars and shared assets
and then it moves to more specific page
source tools gotcha
just so you know I went ahead and shared
the analysis URL in the chat module
folks so you can find a link to it there
along with you mentioned we're in
software as being one of the costs I
think that's who you meant when you said
Marin you know so I went I went ahead
and I shared that in there too so you
folks can take a look at those links one
other link I'm going to show real quick
because you talked about 99designs when
you're talking about a reliable and
affordable way to get some design work
done I share that in there too for
everybody to see if you're not familiar
with 99designs take a look at that and
let's see and Bret says thank you very
much and no problem on the plug more
than welcome to take a look at the
product I'm excited for analysis I know
it's been what more than a year now
since you guys rolled out right I think
- I mean we just launched engrams really
yeah we have Engram analysis for search
queries which I don't think anyone the
world has that unless you don't even
know what engrams are let alone how to
use them so it's it's actually really
cool looking at erm in since that and
how you really find patterns among
queries for negative keywords our new
new ways of looking at positive things
to go forward within your accounts
looking forward to hearing more about
that let's see here we've got another
comment here you mentioned something
about the people are going to spend on
average 30 seconds to two minutes on
their free trial a little bit of hard
stat in the industry and it's kind of a
true average among all product types
it's not a hard stat right but the
amount and it depends on the on what it
is but like I used to do a lot of work
with one of the big task manager' tools
so think Trello asana you know whatnot
and that kind of thing and the average
free trial user I believe was 2 minutes
and 37 seconds that was the average
because it was like they made it they
looked at the UI they tried it and then
they never came back and when they
added remarketing to it it really made a
huge difference in their returns because
people would go in in my can't as
management you can try out 50 things in
like all of two hours right so you
really have to find a way to reach back
out to use as well which is email
programs really important to there but
yes that's products free trials
especially no credit card required free
trials couple minutes is is often what
you have to get someone to either decide
they love your product or they're never
coming back again running actually and
you know I we I know that you know over
the course of the years we've done we
are particularly for you to be customers
here at market motive we do free trials
and I will say there's no truth to that
how how little people really spend in
there trying to product out to follow up
on that a little bit just agree to spend
another second on it are the best
practices in remarketing to people who
are currently in a free trial or you
know even those who are already current
customers the kinds of messaging that
works best to get them to say oh yeah
I'm gonna go back in and I'm gonna try
my access and maybe I'll try a new thing
without getting creepy and saying hey
Steve why haven't you used your free
trial yet or something oh yeah yeah
that's that's too much right so what we
do is we say what are our primary three
or four or five benefits right and then
that way we can make an ad to each of
those benefits so that if he user
doesn't care a benefit one but they see
the second one like I didn't know you
did that as well right all of a sudden
you've reengaged them again so I find
with remarketing especially display
remarketing not not so a search that's a
little different intent that making
three or four ads with completely
different messaging even if one or two
you know perform below the average that
the whole is actually better than the
one it's not one plus one equals three
mentality which saw people don't you
know sometimes tough to grasp oh no
housewives taking some beating over that
math but it really does work on
remarketing
remote the geico effect right if you
watch TV for three hours you'll see five
Geico ads and you none of them are the
same right you've got the lizard you've
got the cavemen you've got the talking
sack of money you've got all the
different croissants to hold right I
mean I'm referring the Geico ads that
probably are on the TV anymore but yeah
yeah they had an effect exactly now one
more question I think we have time for
one more here the three site study was
great where you were showing that they
were dedicated to their desktop site and
you had them test a responsive and
mobile only WordPress implementation the
question is did they keep the content on
those two WordPress sites a little
simpler and kind of squeeze page
oriented and same kind of the deeper
high maintenance content for the desktop
version or did they really try to reduce
all of the cons but it's the same the
content was the same because the desktop
RT had squeeze pages right the desktop
had squeeze pages they were just
formatted it in in tables which do not
go to mobile devices well and so they
reformatted the same content into CSS
design so that way owner responsive CSS
or the mobile only site okay the
responsive site exact same content the
mobile site was not because the mobile
site was broken down in a very small
bite-size chunks easy to navigate click
to jump through points so the mobile
site was is completely own design with a
little bit the same content but broken
down in a much more granular focus the
responsive design was same as desktop
gotcha okay
tables in the last 48 hours I came
across one site that was still built in
front page and that was a hundred
percent flash Wow time to learn those
nuts a long time to learn those lessons
yeah I know squeeze in one more winning
win he just came in under the wire here
with
a question and I wanna make sure we get
it what and and you will be as concise
as we can any answer because we're at
the end of the hour what should a
brand-new AdWords campaign focus on
display search video mobile where's
where's the low-hanging fruit I don't
know how well we can answer that
question without knowing more about her
audience you know what for 98% of people
it is Search Search is an intent to find
something and get a question answered
there's some exceptions in that
statement but they're few and far
between if the exception kind of could
be summed up if you do really well on
ask seen on TV offers at 3 a.m.
display is great if you're like why
would we do that
then Search Search has an intent driven
to it that no other channel can touch
perfect 98% I think that pretty much
answers the question yeah fantastic
all right thank you Winnie I hope that
helped okay I'm going to put one more
last link into the chat box here folks
take a look at that that's a link to the
upcoming webinars page at Marcus August
I just wanted you with that Oh where's
oh yeah you've got the the calendar nail
up there fantastic you'll find a list of
all the webinars there at that URL so
you'll see later in June starting next
week with a mobile marketing webinar on
looking at how the auto industry is
changing the way we use telephones and
what we can all learn from that because
the auto industry is on the bleeding
edge of a lot of fun a lot of the best
practices social media social selling we
have an SEO webinar coming up how to
balance your SEO strategies to satisfy
both robots and humans at the end of the
month we've got greg jarboe
with award-winning content marketing
campaigns that are delivering business
results so that's another sort of a case
study webinar into July Brad as you said
we're back with Quality Score revisited
we've also got a mobile webinar set up
in July and if you keep an eye on this
page by the way you will see more and
more webinars added through July and
into artists over the course of the next
week or so we'll start building out that
list even more if you are a member of
market Lotus you will be getting every
Monday an automated listing of the
upcoming webinars just as a reminder
letting you know here's everything
that's in the queue so every Monday if
anything new has been added it'll be on
that list so if you're not seeing that
and you're right now a market motive
member either as an individual or as
part of a corporate team make sure that
you look for that might be landing in
the wrong tab in your Google but you
want to white lift that so that you make
sure that you get that reminder every
Monday morning with that that's the end
of the presentation but it's always fun
to hang out with you here I love it
that's and what I appreciate about your
options and today was a great example of
that is that there was some stuff in
there that was awfully geeky and over
the top of my head as far as actually
using PPC tools which I don't do but
also really accessible to me in the
context of voice of customer and
conversion calls to action testing which
is all stuff that I really love so it's
just a great cross-section of things to
think about so really appreciate it
thank you from Angie everything
absolutely thank you everybody for
joining us wherever you are in the world
have a great rest of your morning day
afternoon the evening get to bed if
you're somewhere where it's the middle
of the night we really appreciate you
taking the time to join us and please
join us again real soon and other than
that take care bye bye everybody